pilots yes right they stay so calm they
navigate it of course they have
assistance with the technology but what
a talented profession that was a white
out right there yes it also makes me not
miss that stuff at all
no no it makes me enjoy it especially
after that beautiful sunset we had a few
minutes great sunset gorgeous and here's
the thing is i asked the viewers to send
me pictures and now i'm getting flooded
with emails
and i'm okay with that i'm okay with
that right that sunset does look like a
movie it does it looks like the s e
hinton book led to a movie called the
outsiders ooh you're right
towards the ending there under the
inning shot oh brian you're always
bringing it back all right 47 degrees
outside right now your winds staying
light look at that change 24 hour change
about three degrees warmer than
yesterday 49 degrees our high today and
i posted in social media earlier will we
reach 50 officially we did not look at
that 49 again 30 overnight for the low
below freezing 57 is where we should be
so we are way below normal but we are
recording on this date with 69 degrees
that was way back in 1997. currently
outside 45 for you in summerlin 46 for
centennial hills 48 for downtown the
numbers continue to drop each hour here
51 for green valley 47 rose ranch
mountain's edge same for you and
henderson you're 47 45 seven hills and
anthem outside of town here you go 42
for prompt 44 searchlight and 45 for
sandy valley and prim at state line
there so the clouds this is our radar
but nothing on the radar so i put the
satellite on you can see the clouds
drifting from west to east but no precip
no showers with that to get that you got
to go way up towards the northwest
there's the system the low just again
impacting the pacific northwest with
more snow in the cascades all over
oregon and some of that rainfall moving
in northern california unfortunately
that's going to bypass us and notice the
stays to the north tracks the north end
all we're going to get are clouds from
it and then later on the week we start
to see a ridge start to develop and that
will actually bring us some warmer
temperatures before this next system
arrives and this next trough
moves in over the weekend and into early
next week cooling us off again but let's
focus on our overnight lows again some
neighborhoods will actually reach below
freezing again look at that some of the
areas on the outsides of town centennial
hills summerlin the lakes mountains edge
32 degrees along with southern highlands
31 st rose parkway and anthem 33 for
henderson and then we'll be in those mid
30s to low 30s for nellis as well 26 for
prep overnight that's going to be cold
33 for boulder city and 40 for your
morning start in laughlin so here your
overnight low it's 35 degrees very
chilly expect those clouds to stick
around overnight and then we're back to
sunshine as the day moves on tomorrow 53
degrees tomorrow high still chilly
though because we should be at 57 mostly
sunny skies and here is your eight day
forecast on top of that we wanted to
show you also the knights home games in
the raiders game on sunday look at that
jumping up to the 60s breezy friday and
saturday and then cooler again next week
that's your weather update brian over
here good to see that warm-up ted the